hey this is the new frontier and you're
gonna be seeing this shirt for like five
or seven worth this is great okay okay I
would say when you can tell when I need
to do larger because I'm either wearing
a concert or a shirt with my face on it
so yeah so you'll be able to get us
whatever and you're used to seeing that
but okay so this is one of those kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy episodes jake
has a croak dream which I love that term
yeah that he's in space and that there's
a rocket ship a banana man and and then
he holds his breath and he dies which
first of all I like the idea how do you
kill Jake and it's sort of like oh it's
okay now you can kind of see how you
know you sort of don't think about like
can he even die oh and he's surprisingly
excited like I had my first big croak
dream well my only croak dream and Finn
doesn't want to go so he of course they
come across the banana man so Jake is
kind of trying to make it happen while
Finn is trying to make it not happen and
at the end it looks like he wasn't in
space he was actually underwater with a
bunch of stuff with the rocket ship and
everything and all the little pieces the
shards they're forming the stars which
was really clever and I legitimately did
not see it coming either which I like
but Finn is there and he kind of saves
him or at least he by him being there
Jake forces himself to save Finn and
they realize it's gonna happen again
then but Finn one you know has to always
be by his side or else he'll die so
which I love just how yeah and they does
that which as if there's not enough so
yeah and he said so I'm just always
gonna be by your side which I'm now
really curious if this show like follows
through somehow with all that stuff
being repeated um actually now that you
say that yeah I'm curious if all the
pieces will fall into place again I
introduce our strange but it's like cuz
I don't want to see Jake die but it's
like okay well he's gonna die at some
point or whatever and just would it be
cool if fan to follow through when you
see it coming your w like oh no this
seems
this is kind of Selleck I find stuff
surprisingly sadder when you know what's
gonna happen and it follows through
so ya can't be not again he's he's like
sorry every time we're affiliates like
he knows he's like oh oh don't look at
me don't look at me yeah don't look at
me is that now what we're watching the
episode yeah only when we film me saying
I'll pop you filming okay okay um but
yeah because I always feel that but like
sometimes it's even sadder when you know
what's gonna happen is story and you
know they can't escape it uh so that
should be kind of cool if they fall
through it they'll be sad but that
probably the point hello there's the
difference between like the shock of it
happening like oh my god and then the
whole thing of oh god it's coming up I
know it's coming here we go gotta get
prepped for it
yeah I actually I mean maybe cuz I'm so
used to the shock death I don't know
it's only people try to use it but I
like do you know what's gonna happen
death um if done right it works
incredibly well yeah so it's if you guys
are gonna pull through that pull through
that that you became cool um but uh it's
it's a good episode I like that I didn't
know if um because you know they're not
gonna kill Jake obviously so I'm like
well how they gonna get out of this I
knew it couldn't be the exact scenario
that they had set up um you know so so
are they gonna do it's just a different
scenario and he doesn't really die or
one they kind of do both and uh I like
that and I like mostly that Finn doesn't
want to go which is you know I'm very
touching everything but Jake is just
sort of like doesn't even flinch he's
like no no I'm saying I'm ready destiny
and stuff and there's something
strangely kind of it's weird but it's
kind of comforting like he has to die so
it's like oh it's cool like hey I know
this was far the deal you know it's cool
oh no come on Finn you're just making
the words come on destiny and it made
these Gavin Bryce he's like after day he
eats the cosmic owl you don't mess with
the cosmic owl
yeah do we did we see the cosmic owl
before well briefly we saw him well
wasn't he cuz I remember that design I
must say I was back with the that thing
in the tree that came to life was that
or something am I thinking of where we
know
that said don't like I thought it's like
a drawing or a symbol or something oh
maybe I don't remember that no to the
Ice King where the Ice King is floating
through the air when you first pretty
much mean I'm saying a lot of people
like me and goes oh you're a sociopath
oh that's right so that was the first
appearance of the cosmic owl
yeah okay huh you don't mess with the
cosmic owl because what the cosmic owl
shows you will happen Wow
okay so that's yeah I totally do
remember it oh but uh yeah and I think
that's what made it a good episode
because we've seen this stuff where it's
like oh it's not like whatever they're
so fulfilling prophecy what you see
happening is not what's gonna happen or
it is but a different way or you know we
we've seen that done before it's like oh
how are we gonna do it okay they did
that way but I think what held it
together like made it really uni was
their reactions to it
damn Kitty Tyrone will you use the paper
in yeah yeah that's totally okay anyway
so uh yeah no I I thought was I fell
weren't that was effective and I like
the two different attitudes to it no I
actually completely agree with that that
you know you do have Jake who's like no
dude this is the way it is this is
everyone's gonna die this is what it is
cosmic owl showed me I'm good and I do
love the part where Jake's holding on to
the rocket and a fins holding on to his
leg and you see him just tearing up and
tearing up and he's like no no other of
course Jake just finally kicks a mom I
don't know why that just made me laugh
the more I just love how hardcore he was
he's just like you don't just today yeah
like rock hard you know sorry thing uh
and I sorta like I like these two
different attitudes because neither one
is right or wrong per se you know it's
there's one where it's like no never
fight never give up you and it's how you
live more and stuff like that but it's
at the same time it's gonna happen
someday I mean all of us are gonna croak
so you know the idea of just no be at
peace with it it'll be better and stuff
like that you know it's it's two very
different attitude
that are both kind of warranted yeah so
no I liked that and I thought it was
pretty cool um I think what it it turns
a funny well okay the banana is where
Dell yep saying that yeah I would have
guessed it like you say he's under glass
most of the time um sugar
the only fan made me think maybe it was
a celebrity cuz he says so little I it
was that they held on him doing the oh
yeah oh here we go
yeah whoa that I'm saying to myself why
was she doing during that though I need
had the glass jar in his head he's doing
what looks like exercises kill me what
some of them were uh when was this okay
something like that the other was like I
he flips around this way but it would
fall on you I can't remember the other
ones yeah
not very active for the camera no I'm
sorry um trying to get it see there you
go
try to give people a show here
everything is awesome sorry it's it's
really in my head yesterday but yeah the
one part that really made me laugh aside
from what the death scene or whatever
really is and the fact that it's gonna
happen again which how the hell is that
all gonna add up again um is the hello
when the talkie underwater it's like oh
bloody and then you just see them
crabbing under Jake and just the the way
they animated the eyes popping out of
the skull with them holding the fret I
thought was hugely funny because I think
it's so hard to make those dah dies
funny
yeah and they do for the most part
pretty good job they make them big big
in the little shines in there and stuff
I mean they do they do variations but
valid especially really made me laugh um
I loved the arrow scene
yeah the arrow is pretty funny doesn't
that's the first time not even the
second time but what it's like let's go
get that first arrow because we're out
of arrows yeah that's our only arrow so
let's go get orders out of there if felt
like there was a bit more randomness in
this one as opposed to other ones like
I'm thing at that ending just again with
him going woo oh yeah
I mean it's like that's something I
won't see in the first season me or like
what the cosmic owl comes in says you
know you're a sociopath whatever I mean
it's like that's you feel like they kind
of got a little bit of that in this
episode again too which is nice cuz
again after some of the past ones are
just so heavy and so depressing and
stuff you know it's like okay well this
is nicer yeah well I agree
all right I like this episode I am
curious now that you especially say it
are they gonna go back down this path at
some point I hope they do I really don't
like when I show cheats like that and
it's like I understand cuz stuff changes
and snot always the same show you
thought but it's like work with the work
within the limitations up for yourself
but also it's a dream I guess so
whatever Nicole you know what you can't
dream about a cosmic owl you cannot mess
with what the cosmic owl will show you
but it could just be a drink no why what
is it's the cosmic owl but just saying
cosmic cow it could be in your dream
tonight you would have to follow
whatever yes I would
cuz what would happen whatever the
cosmic owl shows you will happen
I guess the way it is I'm gonna like
when you're gonna sleep and get sneaky
I'm gonna go whisper the cosmic owl says
he's going maybe just but it's gonna be
like you know can't talk all your money
or something like that I don't got a
thing of changing the baggage but all we
got I'll take it ain't do that yeah no
no no not yet the cosmic owl has not
come to me it's gotta work its way into
your subconscious I don't want getting
my costume and whispered in your oh so
you know now you're being like I don't
know nope I gotta find a cosmic owl
costume I'd pay to see that it's that
way you get all my money see again
therefore it's going to fullcycle
send me links to a cosmic owl costume